[موسيقى]
بسم الله والحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
سيدي رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه
موالاه الكل سمع عن نابوليون بونابارت
صح اذا مو بالكل الاغلب الكل يدري ان هو
كان قائد عسكري
عظيم سياسي محنك كان لا اثره في
التاريخ لكن ربما الكثير ما يفكر فيه ان
هو
كان
سفاح ومجرم حرب ومخادع من الدرجه الاولى
وعنده شعور كثير
بالنقص اللي ادى
الى ظهور حب للسيطره عنده بشكل كبير
جدا الكل سمع عن كريستوفر
كولومبس المكتشف العظيم اللي اكتشف
امريكا لكن حتفكر فيه ان هو انسان
مرتزق عنده شعور صليبي كبير جدا وكان
دائما يسعى وراء المال والذهب
والثروه ولا يتورع عن القتل والاستعباد
اذا ظن ان هذا اقصر الطرق الى
تحقيق
الثروه انا ما اكلمكم عن هذول الشخصين لكن
بكلمكم عن نصيحه وجهت لي ساعدتني ان انا
افكر في اشياء مهمه
في تخصصي وخارج تخصصي وفي حياتي بشكل عام
وما زالت معاي هذه النصيحه الى
يومنا قبل اكثر من 30 سنه دخلت جامعه قطر
بالتحديد في سنه
1990 ومثل ما هو اليوم مطلوب مننا ان ناخذ
متطلبات عامن على ايامنا كانوا كم من مقرر
يعني مش كثار
كان مطلوب ونا ناخذ مقررين في الثقافه
الاسلاميه واحد واثنين اسمهم كذ مقرر
ثقافه اسلاميه واحد مقرر ثقافه اسلاميه
اثنين في اول فصل لخريف 90 اخذت ثقافه
اسلاميه واحد وانا في الجامع سمعت
عن استاذ فاضل دكتور يدرس ثقافه اسلاميه
اثنين وانه
كان ذو
علم واللي يحضرون معه يستفيدون بشكل اكبر
هو الاستاذ الدكتور عدنان محمد
زرزور الله الله يطول في
عمره فقررت ان انا اخذ الماده
معه
ولم يحالفني الحظ
حتى خريف 93 ان الجدول يكون ماشي مع الوقت
اللي يطرحه الدكتور فالحمد لله اخذت
المقرر يعني صدفه قبل 30 سنه بالضبط من
هذا الفصل اليوم احنا في 23 في 93 اخذت
المقرر مع الدكتور عدنان كان مقرر جدا غني
واثر فيني
بشكل كبير جدا لكن اهم فكره طلعت فيها
اللي كانت بالنسبه لي يعني كانه فتح في
مخي يعني ان العلوم
الاجتماعيه
والانسانيه مش علوم بالمعنى اللي احنا
نعرفه نظريات
ثابته قوانين نتبعها واح 1 يساوي 2 لكنها
منتجات
حضاريه تعبر عن الحضاره اللي طلعت منها
والظروف اللي طلعت منها ربما بعضهم يقول
لي خير يعني بس انا لا تنسون قاعد اكلمكم
قبل عن شي صار قبل 30
سنه وانا كنت
طالب خريج نظام
من صغري يعلمني على
الحفظ ويعلمني ان انا احترم اللي موجود في
الكتب واصدقه هاي كان
نظامنا المقرر تحفظه وتسمعه وهو الصح
واللي يقوله استاذ المقرر هو الصح واللي
يقوله المدرس المدرسه هو
الصح فهذا عمل لي شويه
لخبطه وخصوصا ان انا كنت ناوي اكمل دراسات
عليا في
مجال
اجتماعي
مثل علم
النفس تخرجت من
الجامعه وتعينت معيد في جامعه قطر وقبل ما
التحق بالبعثه الدراسات العليا زرت
الدكتور عدنان ها المره الوحيده اللي جلس
فيها معه زرته قلت له انا اخذت معاك
المقرر تذكرني او لا وانا اليوم معيد في
الجامعه وطالع عما قريب الى الولايات
المتحده عشان ادرس الارشاد
النفسي عن عندك اي نصيحه
لي قال لي
اولا حاول انك تتقن تخصصك قدر
الاستطاعه هذا اول شيء مطلوب منك الان انك
تاخذ هذا العلم بحقه الامر ثاني لا
تنسى ان تقيم هذا اللي انت قاعد تفهمه من
وجه من وجهه نظر حضارتنا وثقافتنا العربيه
الاسلاميه خذت النصيحه هذه وانطلقت
فيها كان لها اثر كبير في
دراستي اللي فيكم مطلع على علم النفس
بيعرف ان في نظريات وايد في علم النفس
ربما من اشهر الاسماء اللي تجي واللي
معروفه بشكل في مثلا
فرويد فرويد شو يقول عن الانسان يقول ان
الانسان تحركه
غرائزه غريزه تسمها غريزه الحياه وغريزه
الموت او غريزه العدوان وغريس
الجنس والانسان ما يعرف ومش واعي لهذه
الغرائز هي التحكم في
سلوكياته هل هذا امر مقبول فعلا لفهمي
للانسان
ولا في مقابل فرويد عند مدرسه اسمها مدرسه
سلوكيه تقول اصلا الانسان لا يفكر ولا
غيره الظروف اللي حواليه هي اللي تحتم
عليه ان هو يتصرف بطريقه معينه فالانسان
فعلا ما عنده الاراده
النهوه يحدد سلوكياته اللي حواليه بيئته
ظروفه هم اللي يملون عليه بطريقه او باخرى
شلون يتصرف وشلون يتخذ
قرارات طيب هل هذا
يتوافق
مع ايماننا بان الانسان عنده القدره على
الاختيار وانه يتحمل مسؤوليه تصرفاته
وقراراته او ني حق المدرسه الثالثه في علم
النفس من مدرسه الانسانيه ويا هالمدرسه
اللي كثير من اليوم يطلعون لكم في
السوشيال ميديا ويكتبون ويتكلمون ويقول لك
عبر عن
مشاعرك زين واللي ما يعجبك اتركه ولا
ترافق هايي من هالمدرسه هالكلام
ه يقوللك عبر عن
مشاعرك طيب اذا انا زعلت على امي ولا ابوي
شنو يعني قاعد اصارخ
عليهم مو الكلام اللي ها فعلا يقولون لك
هالكلام هل هذا سلوكيا دينيا وثقافيا
متقبل خلكم اص ايش وادتها اصلا العمليه
على
الانسان فهكذا وقت الدراسه كل الامور هذه
يعني النصيحه هذه عطتني مرجع ارجع له
وابدا اقيم ما اتقبل كل شيء حتى لو كتب
عليه اسم براغ ان اتقبله كما هو وخرج
الموضوع مو بس في الدراسه والتخصص
الاكاديمي لا في الحياه
كلها اضرب لكم مثال كلنا اليوم نستخدمه
بطريقه و باخرى هذا المصطلح البايخ اللي
اسمه الشرق
الاوسط شنو يعني الشرق
الاوسط سمعتوا في المسطرح ذي استخدمتوه
شنو
يعني الدنيا كلها مقسمه ثلاث
اقسام شرق
ادنى وشرق اوسط
وشرق اقصى على الاقل الشرق في بعد الغرب
ها شيء ثاني يعني الشرق مقسم ثلاث اقسام
بس شرق من
هو شرق الدوله المستعمره الرئيسيه في فتره
من الفترات اللي هي
بريطانيا شرق الادنى اللي قريب على لندن
والشرق الاوسط اللي هو في الوسط احنا
واللي حوالينا والشرق الاقصى نروح حق اسيا
واليابان الى
اخره مرجعيتي انا المستعمر في يوم من
الايام هاي مصطلح لااله علاقه لا بثقافه
ولا باعراب ولا ولا اي شيء ولا يحدد هويه
محترمه ما كان الاول اسميه الامه العربيه
مثلا الدول
العربيه مصطل فعلا يعبر عن شيء مشترك بين
الناس يعبر عن
حضاره او مثلا د نسمي الناس الفقار
المساكين اللي كانوا في امريكا نسميهم
الهنود
الحمر لاهم هنود ولاهم
حمر صح ولا
لا زين لكن ل كريستوفر كروبس راح وظن كان
يظنهم هنود يظن انه ولاف على الدنيا ورايح
الهند بال المكتشف
العظيم
زين نفس الشيء لما ي حق التاريخ نابليون
بارت زين صح قاد
جيوش وقض ترى هو اللي قضى على الثوره
الفرنسيه زين
و كون امبراطوريه وذبح خلق الله خلكم اللي
سواه في اوروبا يكفي اللي سواه فينا ارتكب
مجازر من وين لوين اسكندريه للقاهره
لسيناء لفلسطين ما وقف الا وين في عك
لا وعلى فكره هو اول من قال من اتى بفكره
انه يكون في وطن لليهود في
فلسطين ولا كريستوفر كولومبس الناس كلها
تفكر
في المكتشف العظيم اللي هو اصلا ضيع وقاعد
يقص على الملك ويقول احنا وصلنا الهند
وقابلنا فلان وقابلنا علان لكن اول شيء
سواه لما وصل المنطقه اللي نعرفها
بالامريكي قتل الناس واستعبدهم كله عشان
يدل وين مكان الذهب
المخشوش خلاصه القول عشان ما اطيل عليكم
احنا طول حياتنا كلنا كبشر مو بس في
المنطقه هذه نعامل مع منتجات حضاريه
مختلفه بعضها جاي من حضارتنا وبعضها جاي
من حضارات
وثقافات
مختلفه مهم جدا ان يكون
عندنا مرجعيه ما يكفي ان
احنا نتعامل مع هذه المنتجات سواء كان
منتجات فكريه ولا ماديه ولا علميه الى
اخره لابد ان
نفهمها ونفهمها مو بس بالسطح نستخدمها
نفهمها نفهم الاساسيات اللي انبنت عليها
حتى من ناحيه
الفلسفيه هذه الطريقه
اعتقد الوحيده ان احنا ما نكون تبع وان
احنا نقدر نبني حضاره نقدر نتقدم فيها
للامام لكن مع
محافظتنا على
هويتنا وعلى
قيمنا الحقيقيه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته